ja noch das ist ein rekord allerdings
ein trauriger und zwar der traurigste
des tages wir sind auf dem absoluten
nullpunkt angekommen zumindest am
niederrhein der rhein pegel lag noch nie
so tief und die große dürre hat
deutschlands flüsse ausgetrocknet
[Musik]
endzeit stimmung auf dem tiefpunkt im
wahrsten sinne des wortes der rhein
pegel liegt bei null so niedrig wie nie
zuvor gemessen heute morgen in emmerich
kurz vor der niederländischen grenze
wir hatten 2018 das bisherige niedrigste
niedrigwasser das waren 7 zentimeter am
pegel hemmerich und dadurch dass wir
jetzt heute den wert von null zentimeter
am heinrich haben ist dieser wert
unterboten worden
ein schiffswrack wo sonst das wasser
rauscht deutschland sitzt auf dem
trockenen nicht nur hier an der so
wichtigen lebensader des rheinlandes im
spreewald dem paddel paradies für
berliner und brandenburger wurden jetzt
die schleusen dicht gemacht der
hauptspiel fehlt das wasser in sachsen
ist die schwarze elster streckenweise
komplett ausgetrocknet nur das flussbett
zeigt wo früher mal wasser rauschte
zugegeben ein nullpunkt am niederrhein
bedeutet noch kein weltuntergang
aktuell haben wir noch eine
fahrrinnentiefe von 1 meter 96 die der
schäfer zur verfügung stehen aber auch
das ist nicht der tiefste punkt des
rheins es gibt auch stellen die noch
tiefer sind als die der die
fahrrinnentiefe
sprich der schiffsverkehr am rhein ist
aktuell noch möglich allerdings mit
einschränkungen bei niedrigen pegel
dürfen die schiffe viel weniger fracht
auflagen weniger fracht bedeutet kohle
engpässe in kraftwerken waren
verknappung in fabriken und logistische
kostenexplosion in finanzielle schon
angespannten zeiten die dürre gibt uns
den rest
michael engelberg ist jetzt in emmerich
michael sagt uns wie fühlt sich das an
wenn man da steht wo sonst wasser fließt
und jetzt ist plötzlich alles trocken
ja hallo valentina ich gehe mal sofort
schritt zur seite wir stehen hier in
emmerich also man sieht es ist noch was
er da das alte sprichwort es fließt noch
viel wasser den rhein runter das habt
ihr so ein bisschen aus wie wenn man
nämlich wie sieht hier ist schon sehr
sehr viel trocken gefallen hier die die
messlatte die pegel latte die ist auch
schon sichtbar und wir können jetzt mal
mit herrn wolters sprechen herr wollte
das ist ja auch gerade schon im beitrag
gelaufen er wollte das erklären sonst
den pegel pegel 0 und warum noch schiffe
vorhanden da ist mir recht gerne also
pegel 0 bedeutet dass der untere
messpunkt des pegels erreicht dass man
dachte dass auf keinen fall mit der
tiefe des rheins verwechseln sieht man
ja auch hier draußen das ist immer noch
wasser da die schiffe fahren auch noch
und im prinzip bedeutet das dass der
untere wert erreicht es den der hier im
bibelhaus hier oben noch gemessen werden
kann das heißt es gibt ein pegel derzeit
an was sich an wasser nach oben oder
nach unten verschoben hat aber dennoch
ist die wanne voller also das fahren
noch schiffe ist jetzt nicht so dass das
wir alle wie wie jesus über das wasser
laufen können das wird hier nicht
passieren aber in der mitte ist es ja
tiefer warum ist diese fahrrinne da und
wie tief ist diese fahrrinne noch bis
zum bug des schiffes ja also hier in
emmerich ist diese fahren beim jetzigen
wasserstand also pegel 0 1 meter 96 tief
und 150 meter breit und
da steht der schifffahrt zur verfügung
da ist eine definierte tiefe
und tatsächlich es aber so dass diese
150 meter jetzt für den unteren
niederrhein nicht sehr viel sind wir
haben hier soviel schifffahrt dass wir
tatsächlich so viel platz zum navigieren
der schiffe brauchen er wollte das hat
uns gerade erzählt dass das wasser und
schifffahrtsamt nicht dafür da ist zu
sagen so jetzt fertig keiner mehr das
sind die eigner das sind die verlader
das sind die die die leute in auftrag
geben wann ist immer noch wirtschaftlich
ist und die müssen natürlich
letztendlich auch entscheiden wann und
wie sicher es ist jetzt sehen wir da ein
paar schiffe er wollte das jetzt sagen
sie uns mal eben mit wie viel last und
fracht können die noch fahren bis sie
sich eventuell festbeißen ja aber das
hängt von den schiffsgrößen ab gerade
hier am unteren niederrhein fährt
eigentlich alles was in auf deutschen
wasserstraßen fahren kann auf deutschen
binnenwasserstraßen fahren kann und das
ist von den großen schub verbänden die
bis zu 16.000 tonnen ladung mitnehmen
können wenn die voll abladen können
jetzt natürlich nicht mehr bis hin zu
den kleinen spitzen nennt man die
der niederländische spitze reist dass
das in kleine schiffe naja und die
können bei diesem wasserstand eigentlich
noch eine ganze menge der ladung
mitnehmen wie hund mit denen die großen
schiffe diese übergroßen rheinschiffe
im moment für durchsagen nur noch so
rund ein drittel mitnehmen können hier
am unteren niederrhein
ein bis zu einem drittel noch da geht es
darum dass es sich natürlich irgendwann
wirtschaftlich auch nachholen muss wir
haben gerade gehört dass hier auch eine
fähre die beide rheinufer miteinander
verbindet in wesel bislich dass die
schon den betrieb eingestellt hat wir
werden da gleich mal vorbeigucken und
versuchen daraus zu bekommen wie viel
tiefgang diese fähre nach braucht hier
ist man trotzdem vom wasser und
schifffahrtsamt noch entspannt aber man
geht auch davon aus dass wenn es weiter
so bohlen heißt es dass der pegel hier
auch in den minusbereich fallen kann
damit zurück aus emmerich nach berlin
danke michael als ausgetrocknet es sind
die flüsse gott sei dank noch nicht
dennoch hat die dürre deutschlands
gewässer fest im griff
[Musik]